selon les témoins il est 19h30
lorsqu'une voiture avec à son bord
quatre personnes s'arrêtent à proximité
de plusieurs jeunes rassemblés dans ce
parc situé entre la départementale 13 et
la rue des commandos d'afrique
les occupants du véhicule cagoulé
ouvrent le feu heureusement sans faire
de blessé par peur de représailles
les témoins qui ont assisté à la scène
n'ont pas souhaité s'exprimer devant
notre caméra
en revanche ils nous ont tous confié
avoir peur et être traumatisé par la
situation car ce n'est pas la première
fusillade dont le territoire de belfort
le 4 septembre dernier un homme a ouvert
le feu avenue jean jaurès à seulement
deux kilomètres du quartier de l'arceau
à offemont existe-t-il un lien entre ces
deux affaires
pour l'instant ni la police ni le
parquet n'étaient joignables pour
apporter des précisions
mais les élus s'inquiètent parce que je
dénonce aujourd'hui un développement
jamais vu du trafic de drogue sur
belfort avec vraiment au grand jour
maintenant avec des règlements de
comptes à coups de feu avec des trafics
qui se font devant les écoles qui se
font dans la rue et on a vraiment un
sentiment d'impunité et la population a
vraiment un grand ras-le-bol par rapport
à tous ces problèmes de drogue quant à
damien meslot
il a sollicité l'aide du ministère de
l'intérieur
j'ai écrit à gérard collomb pour lui
expliquer que j'étais inquiet suite à
ces deux fusillades qui s'était déroulé
sur belfort heureusement sans grande
gravité
mais je lui ai écrit pour lui dire
j'étais inquiet je lui demandais de
renforcer les effectifs de police
nationale sur la ville de belfort la
police municipale sera elle aussi
renforcée puisque le maire de belfort a
annoncé vouloir recruter trois nouveaux
agents